you know I met yo yo jumping back to the
beginning almost five years ago and we
had this incredible conversation and I
came out of that first evening with
yo-yo with that kind of documentary that
intuition saying like I'll follow you
with a camera anywhere like the ideas
you're talking about and your
personality like there's something here
but I don't know what it is so let's
jump off the cliff together did you guys
meet did he come to you has somebody has
something somebody had recommended he
called me about initially was maybe to
do a concert that was going to have some
little documentary elements because
there's so much going on underneath the
surface when you see the Silk Road
ensemble he wanted to talk about
explaining it by the end of that first
night we had hatched this plan to make a
documentary not knowing what it was
going to be and I didn't think that
night that I was going to end up in a
refugee camp three years later and in
fact as the film evolved Keenan hadn't
even joined the ensemble no real so the
first time you ever played with them is
the reporting session that we show so
that all you know the it was all
unraveling or raveling as we were as we
were going and with this way I mean you
the the four people that recites yo-yo
ma that you concentrate on they all they
all have such interesting stories and
sad stories and and and brave stories I
mean they've all I mean it's funny
because when I remember telling somebody
about this film was starting they said
well you know everybody music's
international language or but it gets
together and it's like kumbaya and you
know where's the dramatic tension and
you know yeah I got a lot of that and I
said I think there's dramatic tension
here I mean to me it's this idea in the
west of how we treat our culture which
is you know arts are nice but you know
non-essential we cut our funding from
the government from her school's piano
stores are closing right you know what
do you mean yeah and it's just and
there's a whole other part of that that
yo-yo has been kind of a war for culture
he's been waging which is you know the
culture you know he's been doing a
program
cultural entrepreneurship with Harvard
Business School he has a big curriculum
program he's doing all these other
things but basically making the argument
the stem to steam movement all these
things of adding arts and de science and
technology that the kinds of things we
say we want from our workforce in the
future our adaptability ability to be
creative and improvisational and
collaborative and these are the things
you learned from being an artist say or
being a musician I mean these are that
these are skills that we need that I
think the part with the foreign stories
is reminding ourselves reminding the
audience or myself even that that
artists and other cultures have a
tremendous amount of weight and that
they've paid real real price for being
an artist you know we take it all for
granted here but when you see that other
artists have been xperia door jailed or
kicked out of the country because of
their art that it really tells you
something i mean the idea as I started
to think about cultural revolutions you
know whether it's in China or Spain or
Iran or Syria they don't call them
cultural revolutions by accident you
know that the easiest way to subjugate
somebody or a culture is to erase their
culture because that's how they define
themselves that's how they have a sense
of identity so it was some of these
issues of looking than trying to pick
the stories of people to represented a
diversity of those kinds of experiences
well I was reading that you went after
you met with yo-yo ma that you kind of
went to Hong Kong and watched a concert
is that so did to get when did all of
this kind of form in your head that this
is the way to go I met him on a Tuesday
and he called on Wednesday and said can
you be in Hong Kong on Saturday and oh
my goodness and I I was able to expedite
a visa and I got there and just because
the ensemble was beginning a tour and I
could meet everybody then I got on a bus
with them and we drove in a mainland
China and I remember being in rural
China five days after I met yo yo
wondering I got myself into and again
there was something really kind of
electric and interesting about the
people it just
took two years to figure out what the
film was gonna be you know and I think
that two years was also a process of
kind of writing grant proposals and
figuring out how to pay for it and what
and filming bits and pieces and then
kind of after two years it was like okay
this is the direction we're going to go
this changed so much even since you
finished that you didn't expect to be
doing kind of a refugee film in a way
but with the nationalism and the vote on
friday and everything this sort of takes
on a whole new context it does and as I
said the context has been changing even
since we finished the film and you know
I think initially I set out to look at
these questions of tradition and what
does tradition means it means home and
once you start telling these stories you
start evaluating the idea of what home
means and then kind of worried a peak
refugee crisis in the world today
looking at what home means has taken on
a very political meaning and seeing the
context of how the film plays we
screened it in Berlin to an audience of
Syrian refugees that was incredible when
what is it when was that this was in
February around the Burleigh now it's
part of the way before you got the
refugee crisis had as much publicity as
it hasn't it yeah I mean it was more in
Europe it was peaking and here in
America it's all kind of at arm's length
right you know it still feels like an
abstraction so just seeing how that
plays and then even just seeing you know
I mean as I kind of have been thinking
about it and distilling it and even
talking to yo yo about it this idea of
kind of building building bridges or
building walls you know Donald Trump
talks about building walls is that
what's the best for a world or is when
Britain talks about leading Europe is
that what's best ultimately for the
long-term health of our society I think
cultures answer is no you know because
culture is like water it connects us in
ways there that are hard to control and
hard to measure I mean I think that's
the disadvantage of culture it's a tough
metric you know it's not like elections
or economics where you can really point
your finger at it and say yeah we did
ten percent better this year it's
something that has this other bigger
influence and I think
the core influenced culture has is
empathy because whether it's music or
its film I mean I love Roger Ebert it
called films empathy machines you know
but I love that idea that that culture
is really about understanding the other
in some way and making them familiar and
seeing something of your own experience
in them and and that's crucial well you
know you put a human face you know we
hear of these refugees or you here are
people who have to flee or ran or you
know or can't go back to use their home
in Damascus or whatever and you just you
see the photos you know on the news or
you see newsreel but here we get to it's
like you know when you watch a great
iranian movie it you see our differences
you see our simula similarities but also
it puts a human it puts a face so we can
say you know it's like never pronounce
their names but the Iranian a on right
you know i mean it puts we know what
he's one of many millions who probably
going who you know lost their parents
lost their brother you know and it has
been you know exile from their country
and we see that absolutely yeah and it's
it's part of what I think yoooo yo had
in mind maybe enough in the very
beginning but certainly after nine
eleven this idea of taking musicians the
Middle East Middle America and musicians
from Middle America to the Middle East
and just trying to kind of have you
understand even just a little bit about
their culture and who they are and that
process the more you can repeat that
process the more difficult it is to to
demonize those cultures right you
realize how similar they are to ours I
mean the other part of it and that the
reason i love the metaphor of the silk
road is the silk road metaphorically I
mean literally it was a trig route where
everything from algebra to Islam de
pasta found its way from what head to
the continent to the other but the
metaphor of it is that all these things
that seem pure emblems of specific
traditions in fact have been a dialogue
with other cultures going back millennia
so whether it's pasta or is
guitar and a guitar or a pipa and a lute
I mean all these instruments are
interrelated and you can get it into it
music logically you can get into it
culturally but the idea that you know
the guardians of tradition and purity
tend to want to grab on to what it is
today right but when you really start to
pull it apart you realize that we've
always been a dialogue with other
cultures right and we shouldn't be
afraid of that right what about to I
mean with yo-yo ma I mean he's such a
personality you see him kind of grow as
a person and he seems happier and he
seems more alive watching him with the
Silk Road absolutely and it's part of
what yo yo talks about to in the filmer
it comes up and the idea of finding your
voice you know and that your voice is
something that's not like you find it
and you say ok done you know I'm just
going to do that for the rest of my life
though they're artists artists to do
that but to most artists that's def you
know that you've got to continue to
evolve and nobody wanted yo-yo to do
this I mean it didn't make sense you
know for nope nobody the manager you
know nobody thought a great idea we're
going to get together a team use itions
from around the world and we're going to
spend two years I'm going to spend a ton
of money and we're gonna have to raise
all that money and we're going to figure
it out this was something that he put
his own personality force of personality
behind and continues to and not just I
mean what's kind of extraordinary about
it is is is much of a presence and a an
expert as he is and what he does he
leads by stepping back I mean his
presence makes everybody check their ego
at the door and he's kind of the first
among equals but in general I think he
stays back when you work when he works
and if it gets tense he'll throw in a
joke he'll throw in a quick idea but
he's very much about trying to flatten
hierarchies and tried to kind of use his
presence just to make everybody feel
welcome and I feel the kind of two sides
of yo yo the kind of deep thoughtful
brilliant artist in the complete
we kind of silly juvenile times you know
very silly he knows a lot of dirty jokes
I also but it's not without purpose it's
that you know when yo yo shows up and he
starts cracking dirty jokes and hanging
out with the guys or anybody you know
I've seen him you know them trying to
drag him out of a hotel and he's talking
to the bellboy for ten minutes about his
kids and it's it's part of yo-yos
ability to kind of instantly take
himself off a pedestal and say it's not
about me like let's let's turn this into
something about us and I think he's
brilliant at that thank you so much for
coming and thanks so much for thank you
song and